say I have a thousand dollars and I  wanted to invest it somewhere where  should I invest it I do believe at that  level the number one thing that  everybody should at least take a real  try at is buying and selling buying and  selling teaches so much go garage saling  or Thrift storeing or clearance aisles  at stores I think it teaches you so much  about human beings what they'll buy what  they won't buy even if you're in a field  that doesn't require it the psychology  of understanding humans through the  process of buying and selling is an  incredible Foundation that leads to  empathy advancements and other things  that really matter